TOMORROW.
TUCKER CARLSON IS UP NEXT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
THERE IS AN AWFUL LOT GOING ON
RIGHT NOW.
THE PRESIDENT FIRED ONE OF HIS
EARLIEST SUPPORTERS IN
WASHINGTON, FORMER SENATOR   NOW
ATTORNEY GENERAL COUNT, NOW
FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF
SESSIONS THERE WILL FOCUS ON
THAT IN JUST A MINUTE.
BUT FIRST, THE BIG STORY, THE
SMOKE IS CLEARING TONIGHT FROM
THE MOST EXPENSIVE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
THE OUTLINES ARE JUST BECOMING
VISIBLE.
THE RESULT, IT TURNS OUT, ARE
CONFUSING.
IT WASN'T EXACTLY A DRAW, BUT
BOTH SIDES CAN CLAIM VICTORY,
AND OF COURSE, THEY ARE PAIRED
IN THE HOUSE, REPUBLICANS DID
SLIGHTLY WORSE THAN AVERAGE AND
A MIDTERM ELECTION.
IN THE SENATE, THEY DID A LITTLE
BETTER.
SOME RACES PLAYED OUT AS
REFERENDUMS ON THE PRESIDENT'S
FIRST TWO YEARS IN OFFICE, OTHER
RACES HAD NOTHING AT ALL TO DO
WITH TRUMP.
IN SOME RACES, HARD EDGED
IDEOLOGUES WON, AND OTHERS,
MODERATES TAPE IT WAS BASICALLY
A PATCHWORK, NO OBVIOUS
TAKEAWAYS FROM WHAT HAPPENED
LAST NIGHT.
BUT THERE ARE SOME USEFUL
LESSONS, AND THAT IS WHAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO SPEND SOME TIME
TALKING ABOUT TONIGHT.
WHAT EXACTLY HAVE WE LEARNED
FROM 470 INDIVIDUAL
CONGRESSIONAL ELECTIONS?
SOME BIG GOVERNORS RACES, AND
THE FULL YEAR OF POLITICAL
DEBATE?
THE BIGGEST NEWS IS THAT
DEMOCRATS JUST WON BACK THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES AFTER
EIGHT YEARS.
THEY ARE THRILLED WITH THAT,
OBVIOUSLY.
AND YET THEY DON'T APPEAR TO
HAVE ANY IDEA HOW THEY DID IT.
AS OF TONIGHT, THERE REALLY IS
NO DEMOCRATIC PROGRAM OR
PLATFORM OR MESSAGE, THERE IS NO
DEMOCRATIC PLAN FOR MAKING THE
ECONOMY STRONGER OR THE COUNTRY
SAFER.
THERE IS ONLY DONALD TRUMP, WHO
THEY DESPISE.
THE ENTIRE DEMOCRATIC MESSAGE IS
TRUMP.
THE PRESIDENT'S OFTEN ACCUSED OF
NARCISSISM AND MAKE EVERYTHING
ABOUT HIMSELF, BUT ON THAT
POINT, DEMOCRATS AGREE WITH
THEM, THEY THINK EVERYTHING IS
ABOUT TO TRUMP COME TOO PAIRED
WATCH THIS CLIP LAST NIGHT.
IT BECAME CLEAR THAT DEMOCRATS
WERE ABOUT TO RECLAIM THE HOUSE,
IT WAS A BIG MOMENT, THE APEX OF
THE NIGHT, AND AT THE APEX, A
SENIOR DEMOCRAT CALLED LISETTE
ON MSNBC TO ANNOUNCE HIS
PARTIES TOP PRIORITIES.
HERE IT IS.
>> I HAVE SPOKEN TO A SENIOR
DEMOCRATIC SOURCE ON THE WAYS
AND MEANS COMMITTEE, BREAKING
NEWS, THEY DO INTEND TO REQUEST
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S TAX RETURNS.
GETTING YOUR HANDS ON THOSE
TRUMP TAX RETURNS, EVERY WINDOW
LOOKS, WOULD BE A BIG DEAL FOR
THE COMMITTEE.
>> Tucker: GETTING TRUMP'S TAX
RETURNS, THAT IS THE PRIORITY
FOR DEMOCRATS, NOT
INFRASTRUCTURE, NOT WAGES, NOT
DRUG ODs IN THIS COUNTRY, THE
SHRINKING MIDDLE CLASS, NOT EVEN
HEALTH CARE.
TRUMP'S TAX RETURNS.
THAT IS WHAT DEMOCRATS REALLY
WANT.
OKAY, MAYBE THEY WILL GET THEM.
MAYBE THEY WILL GET THOSE
RETURNS.
WHAT THEN?
WHAT EXACTLY WILL BE LEARNED
FROM TRUMP'S TAX RETURNS?
THAT A CASINO OWNER ONCE
EMPLOYED A CLEVER ACCOUNTANT?
THAT HE MADE LESS THAN HE
CLAIMED HE DID?
WILL ANYBODY BE SHOCKED BY ANY
OF THAT?
WILL ANYONE CARE ABOUT ANY OF
THAT?
OR AS WITH THE STORMY DANIELS
SAGA THAT WENT ON FOREVER, WILL
VOTERS FIND THEMSELVES
TITILLATED FOR A MOMENT AND THEN
LOSE INTEREST?
WHAT DO TRUMP'S TAX RETURNS HAVE
TO DO WITH THEM, ANYWAY?
THEIR PREMIUMS HAVEN'T GONE
DOWN, IT IS ALL JUST NOISE
APPEARED ALMOST ALL OF THIS IS
JUST NOISE.
FOR THE REST OF US, A PRETTY
SIMPLE LESSON, YOU THINK
DEMOCRATS WOULD HAVE FIGURED IT
OUT, BUT THEY HAVE NOT FIGURED
IT OUT.
CONGRESSMAN JERRY NADLER WILL
LIKELY BE THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, JUST
TODAY, HE WAS ON A TRAIN BACK TO
WASHINGTON FROM NEW YORK AND HE
WAS OVERHEARD BY SOMEBODY LAYING
OUT HIS LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES.
FIRST ON THE LIST?
NOT MAKING THIS UP, IMPEACHING
BRETT KAVANAUGH AND REMOVING HIM
FROM THE SUPREME COURT.
APPARENTLY THAT IS WHAT
DEMOCRATS REALLY BELIEVE VOTERS
WANT, MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE,
GET THAT KAVANAUGH GUY OFF THE
COURT.
POISED TO TAKE OVER THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE, THE
REIGNING MEMBER FOR THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS.
HE SAID COME JANUARY WHEN HE
TAKES OVER, HIS MAIN PRIORITY
WILL BE INTENSIFYING AT THE
RUSSIA PROBE, BECAUSE IT IS NOT
INTENSE ENOUGH OR LONG-STANDING
ENOUGH.
HE THINKS THAT HE CAN PROVE THAT
VLADIMIR PUTIN SOMEHOW STOLE THE
2016 ELECTION WITH A FEW DOZEN
FACEBOOK ADS THAT HARDLY ANYBODY
SAW.
CAN HE REALLY PROVE THAT?
WHO KNOWS?
MAYBE.
WHAT WE CAN KNOW FOR CERTAIN IS
NOBODY OUTSIDE WASHINGTON WELL
CARE AT ALL IF HE DOES PROVE IT.
THE ENTIRE RUSSIA CONVERSATION
IS AN RELEVANT AND A DOME.
AND THAT HAS BEEN PROVEN
ALREADY.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
ANYTHING, AND EVERYBODY KNOWS
IT.
DEMOCRATS ARE THE ONLY ONE WHO
DON'T KNOW IT YET.
AS OF RIGHT NOW, THE ENTIRE
DEMOCRATIC PLATFORM CAN BE
SUMMED UP IN ONE SENTENCE --
DONALD TRUMP IS A BAD PERSON.
THAT IS WHAT THEY PLAN TO RUN ON
IN THE NEXT PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION, WHICH INCIDENTALLY,
STARTS TODAY, RIGHT NOW.
GOOD LUCK WITH THAT.
IT IS A VIRTUAL GUARANTEE THAT
TRUMP WILL SERVE A FULL EIGHT
YEARS TO BE MAKE IT ABOUT HIM
PAIRED BY THE WAY, SO AS ALL OF
THE RACE TALK, THAT IS NOT
HELPING YOU.
SEVERAL ALONG THE WAY, EMMA
KATZ BECAME CONVINCED THEY COULD
WIN ELECTIONS BY ANNOUNCING
VOTERS AS RACIST OR THE ANDREW
GILLUM CAMPAIGN AND TRIED IT IN
FOR TO COMER MEMBER HE WAS ASKED
ABOUT THE FBI PROBE, "YOU ARE A
RACIST FOR ASKING."
STACEY ABRAMS IN GEORGIA, DID IT
WORK?
NO.
IT REALLY WORKS.
WHY WOULD IT WORK?
HERE IS A BIT OF HARD EARNED
KNOWLEDGE FROM ALMOST 30 YEARS
OF COVERING CAMPAIGNS, WHEN YOU
CALL VOTERS IMMORAL, THEY DON'T
LIKE IT.
AND YET THE LEFT CONTINUES TO
THROW THE RACIST SLUR, PROBABLY
BECAUSE THEY ENJOY DOING IT I CN
BECAUSE THEY ENJOY DOING IT I CF
BECAUSE THEY ENJOY DOING IT I CE
BECAUSE THEY ENJOY DOING IT I CL
BECAUSE THEY ENJOY DOING IT I CG
BECAUSE THEY ENJOY DOING IT I CO
BECAUSE THEY ENJOY DOING IT I CD
BECAUSE THEY ENJOY DOING IT I CA
BECAUSE THEY ENJOY DOING IT I CO
BECAUSE THEY ENJOY DOING IT I CT
THEMSELVES.
HERE IS ABC'S COVERAGE OF THE
GILLUM RACE LAST NIGHT PAIRED
WATCH.
>> I THINK PROGRESSIVES IN PLACE
LIKE FLORIDA AND GEORGIA, THEY
WILL BE INCREDIBLY DISAPPOINTED,
AND THEY WILL BE GIVING THEIR
WHITE NEIGHBORS THE HAIRY
EYEBALL TOMORROW.
>> Tucker: IN OTHER WORDS, ABC
IS TELLING US, ANDREW GILLUM
LOST BECAUSE OF HIS SKIN COLOR,
AND HE LOST BECAUSE OF THE
BEHAVIOR OF PEOPLE OF A CERTAIN
SKIN COLOR.
ABC KNOWS THAT.
YOU HEAR THINGS LIKE THIS ALL
THE TIME.
EVERY DAY.
AND YET CURIOUSLY, NOBODY EVER
BOTHERS TO PROVE ANY OF IT.
OR EVEN TRY.
WHY?
BECAUSE IT IS UNPROVABLE.
AND THAT IS THE APPEAL.
RACISM IS NOW ANYTHING YOU DON'T
LIKE, AND RACIST AS ANYONE WHO
IS IN YOUR WAY.
HURLING ALLEGATIONS OF BIGOTRY
ARE FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE
LEFT, THE QUICKEST WAY TO GET
WHAT YOU WANT.
THAT IS WHY THEY DO IT.
IT HAPPENED AGAIN TODAY.
SPEAK ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL, YOU
CALL YOURSELF A NATIONALIST.
SOME PEOPLE SAW THAT AS
EMBOLDENING WHITE NATIONALIST.
>> President Trump: THAT IS
SUCH A RACIST QUESTION PARENTS
BECAUSE SOME PEOPLE SAY THAT THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IS SUPPORTING
WHITE NATIONALIST BECAUSE OF
YOUR RHETORIC.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> President Trump: WHY DO I
HAVE MY HIGHEST WHOLE NUMBERS
EVER WITH AFRICAN-AMERICANS?
THEY LOVE OUR COUNTRY.
I DO.
YOU HAVE NATIONALIST, YOU ARE A
GLOBAL LIST.
I ALSO LOVE THE WORLD.
AND I DON'T MIND HELPING THE
RULE WORLD, BUT WE HAVE TO
STRAIGHTEN OUT OUR COUNTRY FIRST
STRAIGHTEN OUT OUR COUNTRY FIRS.
>> Tucker: IT HAPPENED AT THE TE
PRESIDENTS BRIEFING, SO    SO YU
MIGHT NOT HAVE SEEN IT BECAUSE
YOU ARE LIVING A LIFE NOT GLUED
TO THE INTERNET, BUT IF THAT
HAPPENED A FEW YEARS AGO, IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN EVERYWHERE.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN INTERNATIONAL
NEWS.
AN ACCREDITED WHITE HOUSE
REPORTER CALLING THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES A
WHITE SUPREMACIST?
HOLY SMOKES!
BUT NOW IT IS JUST ANY OTHER DAY
ON CABLE NEWS.
HE NOBODY REALLY BELIEVES THAT
THE REPORTER MEANS IT.
IT IS POSTURING.
AND THEREFORE, IT IS BORING.
THE CLAIM "RACIST!"
IS LOSING ITS POWER FROM
OVERUSE.
DIMINISHING RETURNS HAVE BEEN
REACHED PURITY OF A PROBLEM WITH
NATIONALIST, AND MIGHT BE BETTER
TO ARGUE AGAINST NATIONALISM.
THAT WAY WE MIGHT ALL LEARN
SOMETHING.
IN THE MEANTIME, REPUBLICANS
SHOULD UNDERSTAND THAT DEMOCRATS
CALL THEM BIGOTS NOT BECAUSE
THEY BELIEVE THEY ARE BIGOTS, OR
EVEN BECAUSE THEY CARE IF THEY
ARE BIGOTS.
AL SHARPTON AND LOUIS FARRAKHAN
ARE STILL ALLOWED IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, AFTER ALL,
DEMOCRATS OBVIOUS THEY AREN'T
TOO CONCERNED ABOUT BIGOTRY, OR
THEY WOULD KICK THOSE GUYS OUT
FIRST STEP.
DEMOCRATS SAY IT, THEY MAKE THE
CHARGE, BECAUSE THEY HOPE IT
WILL BRING THEM POWER, AND POWER
IS WHAT THEY WANT.
IT IS ALL THEY WANT.
REPUBLICANS LOST AN ENTIRE
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE -- CONGRESS
LAST NIGHT, NOBODY RIGHTED THIS
MORNING.
AND NOBODY BLOCKED INTERSECTIONS
OR LOOTED LIQUOR STORES.
EVEN REPUBLICAN CONSULTANTS ON
TELEVISION THIS MORNING
QUESTIONING RESULTS OR
QUESTIONING THEM AS A LEGITIMATE
INSTITUTIONS.
IT DIDN'T OCCUR TO REPUBLICANS
TO DO THAT.
IT WAS JUST AN ELECTION.
YOU LOSE IT SOMETIMES.
THAT IS HOW REPUBLICANS THINK.
THAT IS NOT HOW DEMOCRATS THINK.
THEY MEAN IT.
THEY LOST A FEW SEATS IN THE
SENATE LAST NIGHT, ALREADY THEY
ARE DENOUNCING THE SENATE ITSELF
AS IT SOMEHOW UNDEMOCRATIC.
THE TALKING POINTS HAVE GONE
AROUND, THEY ARE ALL READING
THEM.
WATCH JOY BEHAR TODAY TRYING TO
READ THEM -- ULTIMATELY SHE
MISREAD THE TALKING POINTS, BUT
SHE GAVE IT HER BEST ON ""THE
VIEW."
TO BE GOOD DEMOCRATS AND WON THE
POPULAR VOTE LAST NIGHT BY
8 MILLION VOTES.
RIGHT?
BUT THEY LOSE YOU NOT SENATE
RACES IN RED AREAS.
>> GERRYMANDERING.
>> THAT IS THE CONSTITUTION.
THE DISTRICTS ARE GERRYMANDERED,
BUT THE STATES ARE PART OF THE
CONSTITUTION.
>> Tucker: YOU CAN'T
GERRYMANDER A SENATE ELECTION,
OF COURSE, BECAUSE IT IS
STATEWIDE.
JOY BEHAR DOESN'T KNOW THAT, SHE
DOESN'T REALLY KNOW WHAT THE
SENATE IS, BUT SHE KNOWS POWER,
AND LIKE A LOT OF DEMOCRATS YOU
SEE ON TELEVISION, SHE WILL SAY
WHATEVER IT TAKES TO GET POWER.
REPUBLICANS SHOULD UNDERSTAND
THAT.
BUT IT IS NOT JUST DEMOCRATS WHO
SHOULD HAVE LEARNED SOMETHING
LAST NIGHT, THERE WERE MAJOR
LESSONS FOR REPUBLICANS, TOO,
ONES THEY SHOULD PAY ATTENTION
TO.
HERE'S ONE, VOTERS CARE ABOUT
CAMPAIGN PROMISES.
IF YOU DON'T FULFILL YOUR
CAMPAIGN PROMISES, IT TURNS OUT
THEY NOTICED, THEY REMEMBER.
THEY DON'T CARE FOR IT.
IN 2016, REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS
PROMISED TO COME I DON'T KNOW,
BUILD THE WALL, GET RID OF
OBAMACARE, DEFUND PLANNED
PARENTHOOD, THEY GOT ELECTED ON
THOSE PROMISES, THEY DIDN'T DO
ANY OF THEM ONCE THEY GOT
ELECTED PAIRED MAYBE THAT IS ONE
REASON THEY LOST OF THE HOUSE
LAST NIGHT.
HERE'S ANOTHER LESSON.
IMMIGRATION MATTERS.
NOT JUST ON THE LEVEL OF
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES AND
CARAVANS, THE THINGS THAT WE
DEBATE EVERY NIGHT, BUT ON THE
LEVEL OF ENTIRE POPULATIONS.
IMMIGRATION CHANGES WHO LIVES IN
A COUNTRY AND WHO VOTES.
ULTIMATELY, THAT IS WHY IT
MATTERS.
YOU NEVER KNOW THAT FROM
LISTENING TO THE COVERAGE OF
IMMIGRATION STORIES.
YOU WOULD THINK THE QUESTION OF
WHO COMES INTO YOUR COUNTRY AND
UNDER WHAT CIRCUMSTANCES WAS
ENTIRELY A MORAL ISSUE.
REALLY A QUESTION OF PERSONAL
DECENCY.
GOOD PEOPLE ARE FOR OPEN
BORDERS, BAD PEOPLE ARE AGAINST
THEM.
THAT IS ALWAYS A MESSAGE,
INCLUDING TODAY.
>> AS YOU KNOW, MR. PRESIDENT,
THE CARAVAN WAS NOT AN INVASION,
IT IS A GROUP OF MIGRANTS MOVING
UP FROM CENTRAL AMERICA TOWARD
THE BORDER WITH THE U.S.
WHY DID YOU CHARACTERIZE IT AS
SUCH?
>> President Trump: BECAUSE I
CAN SAY INVASION, YOU AND I HAVE
A DIFFERENCE OF OPINION.
>> DO YOU THINK YOU DEMONIZED
IMMIGRANTS IN THE SELECTION?
>> President Trump: I WANT
THEM TO COME INTO THE COUNTRY,
BUT THEY HAVE TO COME IN
LEGALLY.
THEY HAVE TO COME THROUGH A
PROCESS.
>> CAN ASK ONE OTHER QUESTION
PAIRED >> President Trump:
THAT'S ENOUGH, THAT'S ENOUGH.
THAT'S ENOUGH.
>> PARDON ME, MA'AM.
>> President Trump: THAT'S
ENOUGH.
>> IF I MAY ASK, ON THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION, ARE YOU CONCERNE
CONCERNED.
>> President Trump: I'M NOT
CONCERNED ABOUT ANYTHING.
THOUGH INVESTIGATION IS A HOAX.
THAT IS ENOUGH, PUT DOWN THE
MIC.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, ARE YOU
WORRIED ABOUT INDICTMENTS COMING
DOWN IN THIS INVESTIGATION?
>> MR. PRESIDENT.
>> President Trump: I TELL YOU
WHAT, CNN SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF
THEMSELVES HAVING YOU WORRY WORK
FOR THEM.
YOU ARE A RUDE, TERRIBLE PERSON,
YOU SHOULDN'T BE WORKING FOR CN
CNN.
>> Tucker: I HATE TO SEE THIS
BECOME A NEW STORY, A COST OF
SUCH A BUFFOON, BUT HE IS SUCH A
BUFFOON THAT THE WHITE HOUSE
FELT THEY HAD NO CHOICE BUT TO
RESPOND.
PRESS SECRETARY SARAH HUCKABEE
SANDERS PUT UP THE STATEMENT,
"PRESIDENT BELIEVES IN A FREE
PRESS AND WELCOMES QUESTION OF
HIM IN THIS ADMINISTRATION, WE
WILL, HOWEVER, NEVER TOLERATE A
REPORTER LACING HIS HANDS ON A
YOUNG WOMAN JUST TRYING TO DO
HER JOB AS A WHITE HOUSE INTERN.
THIS CONDUCT IS ABSOLUTELY
UNACCEPTABLE, ALSO COMPLETE A
DISRESPECTFUL TO THE REPORTER'S
COLLEAGUES, NOT TO ALLOW THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK A QUESTION."
IT WENT ON TO SAY, "AS A RESULT
OF WHAT HAPPENED, THE
WHITE HOUSE SUSPENDING THE HARD
PASS OF THE REPORTER INVOLVED
UNTIL FURTHER NOTICE CLEAR CLOS
CLOSE.
"
WHATEVER ELSE THE EXCHANGE YOU
JUST SAW WAS, WHAT IT REALLY WAS
IT WAS A DIVERSION FROM THE
POLITICAL REALITY OF
IMMIGRATION.
HERE IS THE POLITICAL REALITY.
CALIFORNIA WAS ONCE A SOLIDLY
REPUBLICAN STATE FOR
GENERATIONS.
IT IS NOW AMONG THE MOST
DEMOCRATIC.
WHY?
IMMIGRATION.
TO DIFFERENT PEOPLE LIVE THERE,
NOT SURPRISINGLY, THEY VOTE VERY
DIFFERENTLY.
SOMETHING VERY SIMILAR IS
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IN NEVADA,
ARIZONA, NORTH CAROLINA, MANY
OTHER STATES.
THAT IS REFLECTED IN LAST
NIGHT'S VOTE TOTALS.
CHECK THE NUMBERS.
DEMOCRATS OBVIOUSLY KNOW THIS,
THAT IS WHY THEY OPPOSE BORDERS,
BECAUSE IT HELPED THEM WHEN
RECOLLECTIONS.
REPUBLICANS, MY PROFOUND
CONTRAST, HAVE BEEN VERY SLOW TO
PICK UP ON THIS.
THEY ARE VERY LITERAL.
THEY STILL THINK IMMIGRATION
POLICY IS ABOUT VIRTUE.
REPUBLICANS ALSO SEEM TO THINK
THEIR ECONOMIC MESSAGE IS
WORKING, THEY ARE VERY PROUD OF
THE TAX BILL THEY PASSED IN
CONGRESS, THE CONGRESS THAT THEY
WILL CONTROL NOT MUCH LONGER.
PAUL RYAN IS ALWAYS TALKING
ABOUT HIS TAX BILL -- BY THE
WAY, THERE IS NOTHING WRONG WITH
TAX CUTS.
BUT REPUBLICAN STRATEGIST SEEM
TO FORGET THAT HUGE PERCENTAGE
OF AMERICANS DON'T PAY FEDERAL
TAXES.
BY DEFINITION, THEY DON'T CARE
VERY MUCH ABOUT TAX CUTS.
IT CUTS TO TAXES THEY DON'T PAY.
FOR THEM AND FOR MANY OTHERS,
THE ECONOMY IS NOT MEASURED IN
STOCK PRICES AND GDP NUMBERS,
THEY ARE CONCERNED ARE TANGIBLE
CONCERNS.
WHAT DOES GAS COST?
CAN I AFFORD TO LIVE IN A SAFE
NEIGHBORHOOD?
WILL I GO BANKRUPT IF I GET
SICK?
THESE ARE REAL QUESTIONS FOR
TENS OF MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
THE PARTY THAT EFFECTIVELY
ADDRESSES THESE QUESTIONS,
GENERALLY WINS ELECTIONS.
REPUBLICANS, FOR WHATEVER
REASON, TENDED TO IGNORE THESE
QUESTIONS.
THAT IS A BIG REASON WHY THEY
JUST LOST THE HOUSE.
BUT THERE IS A LARGER ISSUE THAT
WE OUGHT TO MEDITATE ON, THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IS A
CONSERVATIVE PARTY.
REPUBLICANS ARE SUPPOSED TO CARE
ABOUT FAMILIES, NOT JUST A
LITTLE BIT, BUT ABOVE ALL.
AND YET INCREASINGLY, THE
AMERICAN FAMILY IS VANISHING.
YOUNG PEOPLE CAN'T AFFORD TO GET
MARRIED OR TO HAVE CHILDREN.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE NUMBERS AT
SOME TIME, THEY ARE PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE, THEY ARE SHOCKING.
AND THEY FORETELL AN OMINOUS
FUTURE FOR ALL OF US.
A COUNTRY WITHOUT STRONG
FAMILIES IS A WEAK COUNTRY.
IT IS A VOLATILE PLACE, A
CHAOTIC PLACE, IT IS A PLACE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO POLITICAL
DEMAGOGUERY.
IT IS WHAT AMERICA IS BECOMING.
IF YOU WANT TO STOP THAT SLIDE,
SUPPORT FAMILIES.
IT IS THAT SIMPLE.
PUT ANOTHER WAY, IF YOU ARE
SUPPOSEDLY CONSERVATIVE ECONOMIC
PROGRAM DOESN'T MAKE IT
EASIER FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO GET
AND STAY MARRIED AND HAVE KIDS,
HOW IS IT REALLY CONSERVATIVE?
IF COUPLES ARE TOO POOR TO HAVE
CHILDREN AND YOU ARE NOT
HELPING, WHY SHOULD I COME AS A
CONSERVATIVE, VOTE FOR YOU?
I SHOULD NOT VOTE FOR YOU.
I WILL NOT VOTE FOR YOU.
I WILL WORK AGAINST YOU, THAT IS
MY PLEDGE.
SUPPORTING MARRIAGE AND CHILDREN
IS THE BEST -- MAY BE THE ONLY